TOM MOOR: OK.
Cool.
So yeah, like he said.
My name is Tom Moor.
I'm the co-founder of a
company called Sqwiggle.
And before that I
worked on a company
called Buffer that you
might have heard of.
So the thing that these two
companies both have in common
is that they're both built
by distributed teams.
They're completely
geographically dispersed.
We have no office.
And you know, that's great.
You know having a distributed
team has a lot of benefits.
You can save money.
You can have flexible
working hours.
You can hire the best talent.
But it also has its problems.
You become lonely maybe.
It's difficult to communicate.
You have to spend 50 minutes
setting up calls here,
setting up calls there.
So basically the
idea behind Sqwiggle
is to try and solve
these problems.
And we do that in a couple
of interesting ways.
Basically you can see
everybody on your team
when you're using Sqwiggle.
And the enabling technology
behind that is WebRTC.
We use your webcam to
take pictures of you
through the day.
And then when you want to speak
with somebody on your team,
instead of having to
call them, instead
of having to set up
a meeting, you simply
click on that picture, and it
immediately connects the video.
So I'm going to tell you a
little bit about how it's all
built and how we built it.
But just so you can kind of
get a good feeling of what
the product's about, I'll
give you a quick demo.
If this will work.
There we go.
OK.
You guys can see that?
Yes.
So you can see my team
here that's spread out.
We have Matt in Missouri,
Will in Baltimore, Eric
here in San Francisco.
And if I want to speak to Will,
these pictures are updating
and this is all using WebRTC,
I simply click on Will.
And then he's available.
Woo hoo.
We don't have sound.
But it's that simple, right?
And you know, in the
background there,
all the signaling that
everyone's been talking about?
That will happen just
like that to connect
to that conversation.
If I want to speak with someone
else, I click on them as well.
And they're brought
into the call.
So it's very, very
seamless, very quick,
and you can have immediate
discussions like that.
So I'll just end that.
Bye Will.
I just interrupted his day.
I got a thumbs up from him.
So let me go back to that.
So you can see
how quick that is.
You can have really, really
quick video discussions.
And like I say, without
WebRTC this just
would never been possible.
So why did we choose WebRTC?
Well, first off,
we're web developers.
We don't come from the
telecoms background
like [? Sahee ?] and Chris.
I don't have any
of that experience.
We just had this great idea.
We knew what the problem
was we needed to fix.
We needed to fix the presence.
But we didn't have the
telecoms experience.
And it was just the
right time, WebRTC,
we started on this about a
year and a half ago, WebRTC
was just getting to a point
of maybe production ready.
I'd say we were probably
one of the first production
apps charging for
WebRTC functionality.
We built our first
prototype in Flash.
It was RTMFP.
We took it to the
launch conference.
Showed it to a bunch of people.
Tried to get feedback as you
do like Lean Startup style.
And the feedback was OK.
People liked the idea.
They like the thing.
But the quality, they were
like, this isn't going to be OK.
Flash just does not
have the quality.
If you're going to
use this, if you're
going to compete with Skype
or any of these other video
VOIP tools, then
you're going to need
to have really,
really killer quality.
And at that point, we knew Flash
just wasn't going to cut it.
Also you'd have to
use Adobe AIR if you
wanted to do desktop and ugh.
So we pretty quickly
went off that idea.
Obviously, WebRTC cross
platform, cross browser.
If we want to have an iPad app,
an Android app, desktop apps,
across all the web
browsers, it really
is the clear choice
at this point.
And it's very high quality.
You get a lot for free.
You get the Opus
Audio Codec in there.
You get great security, like
world leading security on it.
And this is all accessible
through the JavaScript API.
So for our team it really
made a lot of sense.
So at that point, we have to
choose, do we roll our own
or do we use one of
the existing providers?
So at that point, a
year and a half ago,
there wasn't really much in
the way of existing providers.
Top Box had just about come
out with their WebRTC solution.
And yeah, so we have
to make that choice.
And we chose, we were a startup.
This video was going to
be our core competency,
we should have our core
competency in house.
So we decided to roll
our own solution.
And I've already put enough--
we had enough frustrations just
with the technology as it was.
Because it was so early.
So we didn't want to introduce
another third party in there
that would delay if there
was a bug or something.
At least if it was a
bug it would be our bug.
And we could jump
on it and fix it
instead of having to
wait for somebody else.
So we went and we
rolled our own version.
Of course it wasn't
without its hurdles.
In the early days, lots of
bugs, lots of API changes.
Performance issues, particularly
with the video encoding
were pretty terrible
in the early days.
You could get one video
on the screen at once.
If you tried to put
two or three on there,
your CPU or your
laptop would just melt.
It really couldn't handle it.
But that's improved a lot.
The echo cancellation, our
first production version
that we charged for, the echo
cancellation was nonexistent.
We just had to tell everybody
to put headphones in.
And we still got
paying customers.
And we also couldn't tell them
how to change their camera.
Because that API
didn't exist either.
But these are all problems
that you just-- this
is what happens when
your early doors.
It's got a lot, lot better
in the last year and a half.
It's amazing how far it's come.
So I'll tell you a little
bit about the architecture
of Sqwiggle.
Like I say, I've got a little
bit of imposter syndrome here.
Because we're all web
developer backgrounds.
We don't have
telecom backgrounds.
So this is kind of how a
bunch of web developers
go and build a
communication service.
We have, its a pretty
standard setup.
We have a rails API
socially it's public.
We let our customers access it.
We give them access tokens and
whatnot, which runs on rails.
And we have app.sqwiggle.com.
That's where we have a very
simple Node.js application.
It pretty much just
serves up static assets.
Every single one of our
clients uses the public API.
So that's is nothing
really there to be honest.
It's initially just
hosting an index HTML.
So that's not interesting.
And then we have
our main website,
which has account
management, sign up,
all this type of stuff.
That is where everything began.
How it starts, everything
is in one application.
And then we just gradually
being unbundling over time.
And we also have a desktop app.
So for the desktop app, we used
a project called Node-Webkit
I don't know if any of you here
have heard of that project.
Basically it wraps a WebKit
process and a Node process
into one.
So you can access Node
functions from within a WebKit.
And so you have a browser.
And you can access
the file system.
And then it puts that inside
of a desktop application
rappa that's cross platform.
So we can have a
desktop application
that is actually running WebKit.
And we can do native things
like we pause the music.
It pulls your music
player when one
of those instant
video calls comes in.
So it's just whoa,
there is somebody there.
It let's us do auto updating,
real desktop notifications,
all that type of thing.
So that's been a real lifesaver.
WebKit is great.
This also has a project called
[? Athim, ?] [? Athim ?] Core,
which is very, very similar.
So if you're a web
developer looking
too desktop applications,
that works well.
For the signaling
stuff, we kind of
managed to pretty
much avoid everything
Alex was talking about just
by using a pass provider.
Just for the early days to
get things scaled up quickly.
So we use Pusher.
And Pusher handles
all our web sockets
and all the presence across
channels at this point.
And we also developed
a little gem internally
called Switchboard that let's us
very easily send the real- time
messages to different
pass providers
or our own internal
systems if we want to.
We've used that when
changing between versions
of Sqwiggle and things.
So that's like a
high level overview.
For TURN, we did the same thing.
We have a domain
turn.sqwiggle.com.
If you hit that up,
it will give you
like you're closest
geographically located TURN
server.
We use Route 53 for that.
Route 50 Amazon's DNS server
has the latency stuff built in.
It's really great.
And we use the
rfc-5766-turn-server,
which I think most people use.
It's very solid.
And we have these hosted on
Digital Ocean instead of Amazon
actually.
We found that the
bandwidth is more than
sufficient across many
little digital ocean boxes.
And we have those in all of
Digital Ocean's locations.
So I think that's four
now, Singapore, Amsterdam,
New York, and here.
So that's been fairly
easy to be honest,
the TURN side of things in
a very basic implementation.
And you may seen, I'm
not sure if I had it
on when I showed the demo.
So we have the present system.
You could see everybody there.
And the way that's done
is we use getUserMedia.
We capture the camera.
We chuck it into a canvas.
We do that.
It's kind of intelligent.
It's usually about
every 15 seconds.
But it goes up to a
minute, three minutes.
If there's just an empty chair
there, we don't take a picture.
Well, we take a picture.
But then we don't send it.
And then on canvas, we can
do all sorts of filters.
We filter people for
privacy and things like.
As we have this
honeycomb filter so you
can see if someone's there.
But you can't see
if they're picking
their nose, which a
lot of people like.
And then we base 64
and code the image
and shoot it over web sockets.
So all of that, there's
just thousands and thousands
of web socket
messages going there.
And the quality comes
out really well.
It's amazing what you
could fit in 10 KB
when you use WebP,
which is what we use.
We've used Google
throughout the stack really.
And the chat is the same.
It's all over web sockets
with a rails back end.
So I won't go into
much detail here.
Because I think it's
fairly standard.
And if you've
implemented this before,
you'll kind of know
what's going on.
But just a high level
overview of our signaling.
So when you click on someone, it
does a post request to our API.
The API knows the current state
of the user, the current state
of all the conversations
in the system.
Obviously, we write a
record to the database
to say this
conversation started.
And then it shoots that back
to the client over web sockets.
with the current state
of the conversation.
So it says, hey, Tom and Eric
are now talking to each other.
That goes to everybody
in the organization.
Analysis update
so that everybody
to see who's talking to
who even if they're not
in the conversation, which
is really nice from a company
transparency point of view.
It let's you jump into
conversations just
like you would in an office.
You'd see that two people were
talking to each other, right?
So that was kind of
the idea behind that.
And then from that point, the
clients that are involved,
they know their own ID.
They know they're
involved on the front end.
They initiate the standard
offer/answer hand shake.
This is all done over web
sockets pretty much directly.
It goes via pusher.
I've missed that out
of these diagrams just
for clarity's sake.
So yeah, you do the
offer the answer.
And then ice candidates
is sent an array.
We throttle that to every 100
milliseconds or something.
Otherwise, every time you get a
nice candidate from the WebRTC
stack, it would send
a single message.
And there'd be hundreds.
So it ends up like three or
four ice trickle messages there.
And where are we up to?
Yes.
So well, once you got the
trickle set up, that's it.
Offer, answer, ice candidates.
In theory the media
connection is created.
It might go via
our TURN servers.
It might not.
It might be direct.
And you should have the video
connection at that point.
When you want to
end a conversation,
you just do a delete
request to our API.
And it will, again, the
API will figure out,
it knows how many people
are in the conversation
or if to just throw
you out of it.
And then sends an updated
packet down to everybody
in the organization so
that we can update the UI.
And say, this
conversation's finished
and that type of thing.
And then anybody was involved
will do another post request
to the server with
just a massive JSON
hash of all of the information
that we could get out
of the get stats
method basically plus
a bunch of other stuff.
So we just store a big JSON hash
of what the packet loss was.
What did video connect?
Did audio connect?
What echo cancellation
details were there?
And then we can go
through that later.
And we graph things like average
packet loss across the servers,
across the TURN servers
and things like this.
And it lets you easily
find out problems
before they get too big.
So that's kind of our
current architecture.
So as you saw, we have
this big grid of faces.
And at the minute,
it's all peer to peer,
which is kind of sucky.
I can't remember who said it.
But one of these
guys said, you start
to lose messages and
things like this.
And everything has to be done
in a very, very specific order
because of the way
that WebRTC is set up.
So when you have three,
four connections,
you're encoding three
or four videos as well.
So the front and starts to
lag down in terms of CPU
and things like this.
So you really don't
want to be doing peer
to peer when you have
more than one on one.
And that's just
something we've had
to do up until now just
in terms of resources.
But we've been building our
own multi-point control unit
architecture, which we're
halfway through at the moment.
So this isn't going
to be as detailed.
I'll give you a high level
of what we're doing there.
Because I think it's the
more interesting part.
So we have a C gateway, which is
wrapped in a Golang interface.
So actually what we have is
on each server, on each box,
it has multiple
gateway processes.
And then all of those
gateway processes
are controlled by a
single Golang process.
And that basically it
lets one of them go down.
It gives you a little
bit more leeway
if there is a problem there.
And then we use
RabbitMQ to communicate
between the multi-point
control unit and our own API.
And then the API basically just
chooses which of the hardware
MCUs the messages go to.
So it looks like a little
bit something like this.
If you have a post
request again,
but this time we send an STP
offer with the post request.
And I haven't put
the JSON on here.
Because, in all honesty,
we're still figuring it out.
So you send the
JSON offer with it.
The API knows, OK I have
x number of MCUs running.
It knows the loads of them.
It knows which
ones are available.
And it sends it to the most
appropriate MCU over RabbitMQ.
And then on the MCU user end
when it receives that message,
it creates a video room.
It publishes the user
to it with the SDP
and generates an
answer, response,
which is sent over
RabbitAQ, back to the API.
And then back over web
sockets down to the client.
So you've got the offer
and the answer there.
And at that point, you
publishing your media
to the server.
So you have to do that once
with the MCU architecture.
And then when
another client joins,
they do a PUT request to
that conversation to say,
I've updated my offer.
They do they offer, answer.
And it's a similar thing.
But except at this
time, they also get
offers for all of
the people that
are publishing to the
server so that they
can send an answer
back and do the stream
the other way around.
So you end up with
one stream going up
and n number of streams
coming back down,
which is much more
efficient obviously.
And it's a lot easier
on the client too.
So unfortunately, I don't
have a lot of detail on this.
Because we're literally,
probably those guys
are literally programming
it as we speak.
But I could probably answer
questions if you have any.
And that's pretty much
how Sqwiggle is built.
And I don't know
how long that was.
It was probably
about five minutes.
[APPLAUSE]